uh
good morning everyone this is
a phd candidate final year awaiting
final defense
uh from india at national forensic
sciences university
uh i would like to first of all thanks
lab roots team for this wonderful
opportunity
next i will introduce myself and what i
do
and how my university functions and then
i will
directly dive into the topic which is
neosomes as a bilayer
nanocarrier for combinative drug
delivery
let me move on i will just start
with a brief uh pictures of a wonderful
university
uh it is the national forensic sciences
university as i said it is an autonomous
university
a one of its kind and it's the first
university is dedicated to forensic
sciences
in the whole wild world and i am
specifically in the department of
research and development
catering to the applications of drug
delivery
and nanotechnology
i have been koga i have been guided by
my supervisor
associate professor dr deepak rautani
who has helped me
in my research career in developing this
novel ideas for my research
and gardening applications for different
diseases
so let's start with the topic
my topic is neosomes as a bi-layered
nano carrier
for combinative drug delivery uh so
today i'm going to talk about
a few things about what actually are new
zones some of
you might be already aware about it
different kinds of nano carrier drug
delivery and
why specifically combinative drug
delivery has its significance in the
current scenario of therapies and
treatment also i will share some light
upon the recent examples
on nano carrier-based community therapy
and finally i will be discussing my own
research in this specific topic
and how i achieved those goals in two
different
therapeutic areas that is tuberculosis
and
breast cancer and finally we will
discuss about the summary
and future directions as to where this
research
will lead to the future students and
what might be expected out of this you
know in the long term
so as i said new zones might be
aware to some of you but let me tell you
and define it again for you that
neosoons are nothing but non-ionic
liposomes which are self-assembled
amphiphilic nanostructures
formed when a non-ionic suspection
and polar lipids such as cholesterol are
mixed together in a specific ratio
as it is a bilayer structure it is
obvious that we can
use it for entrapping lipophilic as well
as hydroflix drugs in a single vesicle
this has been also previously achieved
with liposomes
however there are some issues with
liposomes which
we will figure out here uh
and uh give the advantages of new zones
specifically over those new zones just
uh to advance or look forward for the
better industrial applications and
patient care
as i said leaves of liposomes have been
there for a various time
including cancer has been reported
however some issues like
low physical and chemical stability
higher
miscellaneous solubilization and higher
cost of phospholipids
which is a bigger issue and also
stability and difficulty in suspects and
derivatization
are some of the main issues which we
encounter with preparing liposomes
and also lack of method optimization for
preparation is also a big concern for
liposuction
and compared to that new zones have
showed a better control over these
issues and have
really shown some good potential for
future therapies
itself which i think which may
uh replace this neuro liposomes
and can be used for a better application
in
[Music]
the world
these are some schematic diagrams of
what actually a bi layer looks like
the outer portion as you can see
is a lipophilic portion where it can be
used for
entrapping lipophilic or water in
soluble drugs
and the internal aqueous core the bigger
circle inside
can be used for entrapping water soluble
or hydrophilic drugs
the method of preparation varies
accordingly for both liposomes and new
zones and i will also discuss how
we optimize the specific method and
achieved the
formation of neutrons in a much better
shorter time and
better control over the
other characteristics of the vertical
so let's discuss the main thing here
that why
combinative drug delivery is important
here and
its current significance in the scenario
right now
so treatment of many diseases as we know
require multiple doses of one or more
drugs in a combination
which you might be aware of you
taking too many tablets at a time or
during the day
so which ultimately in the long term
causes increased side effects
extractions uh dosage of drugs also
increases time to time there is a
failure due to that the failure in the
com
compliance of the patient is there and
also it
there is a threat of recurring of the
same disease for a
secondary infection or a disease and to
come to that combination therapy is good
to tackle this above issues
which directly reduces first of all the
duration of the therapy
also the side effects and ultimately uh
the drug efficacy viability and
the distribution to the target is
significantly increased which uh
shows a better profile of the drug and
safety also
and for that nano carriers like
liposomes new zone
and many other lipid nano carriers like
solid liquid narrow particles my cells
have been used
extensively for for application in the
treatment of
various however their
industrial applicability uh is
very low
due to the stability and cost
constraints and
increa i mean scaling up to the
industrial level
it fails a lot so this is
the main issue with lots of nano cars
and nano medicine in general
now as i said there have been
extensively studied
in the past and there are actually
several promising reports
the different times which are showcased
the truth potential potential of
nano care resistance uh specifically for
combinative drug delivery
which could change the paradigm of this
specific therapies
and the basic reason for utilizing this
therapies
is to counter these issues and provide a
sustained release for a longer time
which ultimately as i said decreases the
therapy
duration and decreases the side effects
and
significantly increases the drug
efficacy and action
and also it tackles the issue of
patient suitability and compliance
and also as compared to liposomes and
other lipid carriers and neosomes
uh as for my research have been
providing a better stability just
which increases its industrial prospects
as well
there are some two examples of uh
combinative
drug delivery achieved by using nano
carriers or specifically lipid
nano carriers in a recent study by
varsha sharma and the team in 2015
introduced this concept of
self-degrading new zones
which entrap both hydrophilic and
hydrophobic drugs
in a single neo-normal system or in a
single vesicle
for anti-cancer applications and the
results showed that the
drug efficacy was significantly improved
when compared with the free drug
combination uh which shows the true
potential of this study
in nashville similar study carried out
by samaya the talent team
in 2018 dual drug loaded new zones
uh comprising of glyphized and metformin
was formulated as an anti-diabetic
formulation
and again the results showed a better
drug profile
over free drug combination and also
showed a sustained drug release of
up to 14 hours and higher drug
entrapment efficiency
which correlates with the decreased
duration
of therapy and increased drug effect or
action
and also there have been some
applications in the areas of
oncology like breast cancer infectious
diseases like tuberculosis and also
somehow some have been reported that
it also possesses some antioxidant
application
so uh from this onward i will start with
my
uh own research as how i achieved uh
using this specific nano carrier called
neo zones and
uh proved the conceptual validity of
combinative drug delivery in the areas
of breast cancer and
tuberculosis specifically so for
the cancer i selected specifically
breast cancer
where a very common combination of drugs
is usually described by
doctors which includes the drugs that
are democrat and toxological
cycloporticide etc so just for
the our research we selected one
uh hydrophobic drug and hydrophilic drug
uh which acted as stem oxygen as
hydrophobic and toxology is hydrophilic
and for the another project that is
tuberculosis and neozone we
selected uh the drugs kitchen amide and
d
cycloserine which are mostly used as a
combination
as for the recent whole 2016 update
which states that using a combination of
drugs
results in a better treatment strategy
over the long term
so this was the main reason behind
selecting those drugs
and ethiopia these cyclocerine were
those specific drugs which
provided lots of discrepancies in their
antimicrobial efficacies
which propelled us to select this
specific threats and
go forward with the research
so to develop the plan of this work
which was the combination of drug was
had to be done
in the first time and do because the
first step
of any formulation is preliminary
studies and
after some success in the preliminary
studies
optimization studies and of the
formulation has to be done uh using
experimental designs and other
techniques
which is followed by the
characterization of the drugs using
different analytical
and advanced ultrastructural
characterization techniques
and also as the
drugs and the treatment therapy was for
anti-cancer breast cancer and
tuberculosis
for cancer we perform in english when we
cytotoxicity assay
followed by the nanocarrier uptake study
which
uh showed the potential of neozone
generalization in the cells and showing
a better drug effect
in comparison to the free drip
combination and for in the
tuberculosis neo zones uh we performed
enemy pro
minimum inhibitory concentration study
and for both the series we also
performed the
combination index which uh shoot the
synergism of this work
and which can be uh used by the
researchers
for further studies for different
applications and different
therapeutic areas
so this is just a schematic of how
the new zones were prepared and
specifically
this method called ethanol evaporation
method
was uh extensively optimized for
the to gain the new zones or to obtain
for prepared museums in the shortest
amount
of time possible it took around
two years towards uh in comparison to
conventional uh uh bi-layer vertical
separation techniques like
skin film hydration methods uh we
selected ethanol injection method
which took around two to four hours uh
for
the complete preparation and
homogenization of our museums
compared to thin film migration which
almost takes around a day to
prepare those bilateral residents so
it's a very simple method in which we
use
the mixture of cholesterol and the
non-ionic subsection
specifically spawn 20 in a 1x21 mixture
and then we subjected it to a
high speed homogenization at around 8 to
9000 rpm
and as you can actually imagine that
both this organic phase and existence
has to be mixed together
so the as you can see the small
injection
size fixer you can see that contains the
organic phase which contains
the hydrophobic thread and as well as
the mixture of
liquid and non-annex effect and this was
mixed
in a drop size manner and rounded to
9000 rpm
with high speed homogenization followed
by removal of the solvent at 60 degrees
celsius and storing in a refrigerator at
428 degrees
celsius for complete optimization which
took around
two to four hours for the complete
preparation of goals which were then
further
carried out for the stability and
compared to
this uh this was the shortest amount of
uh
time we got for uh repairing new zones
compared to other procedures like uh
skin cell migration and sonication
method
so the nasa initial successes in the
preparation of new zones and the
stability of around one to two months
in the initial stage we carried out the
optimization of the formulation which is
one of the most important steps in
formulation design
and we use box bench and experimental
design
using design expert software and
in which the variables independent
variables and dependent variables has to
be selected
as to study which
variables are affecting the size
and entrapment efficiency of the
neutrons which were
redependent variables so follow the
ratio of cholesterol and 120
ratio of drugs and the speed of
homogenization were selected in
independent variables
and the whole procedure was run for
15 formulations
we had to perform 15 different we had to
prepare different
tactics for the whole thing and after
that the most
suitable the lowest particle size
neutral
and highest consistent efficiency for
both letters
were selected for further cells which
will be
just showing the next slide
as you can see the table here uh for
both
dual anti-cancer and dual
anti-tuberculosis
there was a very high significance that
we observed
after the regression analysis for both
the
uh projects as you can see the y1 in the
response section of the table
is particle size of the nozzle and the
y2 and yp are percentage
encryption deficiency of both the drugs
that is different doctor
vision for anti-cancer drugs and
if your number and b cycle study foreign
ratio
uh was selected to be one hq one for
full equivalent point twenty
the drug was point twenty five in
comparison to one h1 ratio
and the steady speed was selected to be
8500 rpm
similarly in the case of uh
anti-tuberculosis new zones the drug
ratio was even higher that we were able
to interrupt even a
higher amount of thrust which is
corresponding to 0.375
uh mg so there is two one human ratio of
cholesterol and spontaneous and the
results that were obtained were
less than 200 nanometers for both the
projects
in the case of dual anti-cancer neutrals
the optimized formulation had a
vertical size of nanometers
with an entrapment efficiency of more
than 70 percent for both the trucks
as you can see in the table and also
in the case of dual anti-tuberculosis
neutrons we got even a better result
uh which showed that the new zone had a
particle size of
137.41 nanometers and
a percentage entrapment efficiency of 96
percent in the case of picturenamide and
seven to seven percent in the case of
two cyclospan
the the next step was to characterize
the new zone
after successful optimization of the
formulation
the first and foremost were uh of the
observing the particle size and the
potential of the neurons
which were followed by drug significant
compatibility
from the formulation entrapment
efficiency
and in which your drug relief profile
props address from the news
also surface morphology of the new zones
were
observed using microscopy techniques
like afm
and transmission electron
and to assess the stability and
safety of this formulation uh for iv
purposes also
in which one hemolysis essay was used
when performed to determine the
individual biocompatibility
and in the end we also perform osmotic
shock study
to obtain biocompatibility in different
media
and
i'll start first of all with both the
results results
for both the new zone
this was the parameters evaluated as i
already discussed that the dual
anti-cancer movement stored a
particle size of less than 200
nanometers for
180c 0.6 nanometer and a zeta potential
of minus 26k
with a cvi of 0.09 which is considered
to be a very good pdi
which corresponds directly to the
stability and
uh homogeneous dispersion of the
population
the drug release was for both the uh
minimum of therapeutic areas that up to
three days
and a robot stability of six months and
the referee duration at four to eight
degree celsius was observed
for both the new zones uh
in terms of gradient compatibility using
fcir and dxd study
there were no specific interactions
found between the drugs and experience
which shows the compatibility of the
drugs with the
existence used which were just uh lipids
and the non-expectant
and also the serum stability study
showed no change
in the absorbance of the solution
which corresponds to no turbidity and
hence a book in vivo by compatibility
for
highway users
in terms of osmotic study there was no
change in the vehicle diameter at all
in the saline and isotonic medium
however
in uh as expectedly in hyper hypotonic
and hypertonic medium
the the vesicle diameter was
subsequently changed
which was expected
and in the size of the oxygen study was
performed for dual anti-cancer neurons
there was a 16-fold instrument observed
over the
pre-drug combination which showed a
significant strategistic effect
and a greater nano carrier update which
shows the potential of this
fuel and dual drug loaded museum for a
better combination
reaction and for dual cuban classic new
zones
uh 50 percent improvement in the
anti-microbial effect was observed in
this case
too uh in comparison to the plain
combination
along with a good challenge
let's quickly go through some uh
microscopic images of the
vesicles as you can see the afm uh the
same images of black neutrons
which shows a clear spherical structure
and is in good correlation with the
dna spectrum these are the
temp images of a dual anti-cancer museum
and you can clearly see a bi-layer
surface
i mean by lab it can be clearly visible
in the new zone
structure which shows or confirms the
entrapment of the drug and homogeneous
formation of the moon
these are the imaging same images of
dual
classes again it also shows a good for
formation of bilayer around the vesicles
which correlates with the better
stability and
good dragonflat this
are the images for ftr characterization
for both
uh dual anti-cancer neurons and uh dual
energy keyword classification compared
to
cholesterol and spine 20 in the
there was no peak observed for the drugs
in the spectrum of new zones which shows
complete entrapment of the
drug inside the vesicles and
no significant interaction of the drug
with any accident
which shows the good stability and
compatibility
a specific observation can you then can
be seen in the
broadening of the os peak as you can see
uh i have marked that thing here the
especially
this extension of the osu can be seen
due to the addition of water molecules
while preparing the new one
only the peaks of cholesterol and
spine20 were visible
in both the blank museum spectra as well
as central globally
etcetera which again correlates or
confirms the drug entrapment
and shows the good stability of the user
next i will show you the dfc thermogram
dxc thermograms and this
characterization
you know and a very specific observation
was found in this as well
that as you can see exo-specific
exothermic heat
around 236 degrees
can be clearly seen for all the neutron
samples
which stores conversion of the drug into
amorphous form
and this also correlates with the
good amount of stability and no
interaction of the blood with the
extreme
as there was no shift of anything
instead there was
no peak at all of cholesterol respond
when divisible
and this means after some extension
review uh this means that it has
converted into an amorphous form and
indicates a good
stability and compatibility of the drugs
with the
height cooking
these are the drug release spectras of
uh both the studies
the first two graphs can be seen uh for
the
democracy loaded neo-gold
and this was this were carried out at
different ps's
and cl 7.4 to
simulate the normal conditions and at ch
5.4 to stability cancer cell condition
and as imagine the expected the
red release was a bit faster at 5.4 due
to
uh higher ph lower ps however the drug
release was sustained
uh yesterday which was up to
three days in both the cases similarly
in
anti-tuberculosis museum in the final
draft
uh it was carried out at the normal ph
and again the drug release was up to
three days for ethiopia
for 72 hours and for recycling it was up
to
two days at the bottom you can see the
ic50 evaluation in the terms of
microgram per ml
and as you can see i have noted down the
iccc values of the cancer neurons
and you can clearly see the improvement
of the i360 which correlates with
anti-cytospec
uh and it correlates with the cytotoxic
effects of the
formulation and
the democracy tend to stop for
it shows uh very high cytotoxicity
followed these are some microscopic
images of the same
source
it is quite well understood that with
increasing concentration
the cytotoxicity was increased
which is clearly visible here the upper
right
graph shows from three right combination
uh spectra and the lower the right
source uh
spectra for 10 o'clock
this was followed by the nano carrot
uptakes please again
as expected uh the nano carrier which is
drug loaded only showed a better drug
uptake
in comparison in comparison to the
plant-loaded neurons
which shows also confirms
that why such a higher cytotoxicity
effect was observed
the main thing to observe here is that
or the main
inference from this nano carrier study
can be taken that
due to the drug loading or the
entrapment of the thread inside the
vesicles
the density of those vesicles are
increased which
shows higher drug effect or fekc
or type toxicity as you may say and it
clearly shows from the
diagram that with increasing
with increasing concentration the
intensity of the color intensity of the
treasure is increased and
upstages the lower image shows the
uh different areas of the cell the blue
the blue image shows the uh updating the
nucleus
uh section the beam and red flows in the
cytoplasmic section
and this is the merged image which shows
the increase
intensity of the dual drug loaded
neurons
uh which correlates and corresponds to a
better cytotoxic
and the b spectra shows the
flow cytometry analysis the quantitative
way which
proved that uh due to increased drug
loading
there has been an increased drug update
on the nano carrier uptake in the cells
which
indicates a better catastrophic effect
this is just a summary of the
anti-cancer neurons
where it shows that before the treatment
of cells should be
this is before the label of this is the
fidc label spectra of blank new zones
compared to fidget label
of the ultra chloride neutrons and you
can clearly
see the difference in the intensity of
using both qualitative and quantitative
this is the stability of the formulation
uh starting at day one and a day
six months
finally said foreign
mi2 study was done to evaluate the
anti-microbial effects of the
fluoride museums and especially here too
we observed a better better
antimicrobial effect for the
dual technology compared to the freezer
combination
and as you can see the freezer
combination scored
62.52 microgram per ml mit
which was 60 higher than the
mit of symphony plus three cyclo
celebrities
number two uh we showed uh fifty percent
lower
mit which indicates a better effect and
the lower
amount of drugs needed to be used for
this business
he also for a good amount of comparison
we also
perform uh the same analysis for all the
studies
in terms of single drug-loaded newborns
just to get a better comparison
and finally uh combination index values
were
studied or evaluated to
calculate the standard specifics of the
formulation as you can see the
combination index value of the new zones
is comparatively lower
to that of greater combination and which
indicates
better signage
and finally the orthotics of study shows
uh the visual inspection of the vesicles
in different media
as you can see the in hypertonic medium
in the first image
upper and lower you can see the
shrinking of the
red cells in the hypertonic medium and
subsequently as we move forward in the
slide that is pbs
and isotonic media the retains his size
which indicates its compatibility uh in
different media and for
different groups of administration
and again with the hypotonic you can see
the bulk structure of
the vesicles which eventually got burst
due to the hypotonic
the highlights uh as we come to the end
we will discuss the highlights and
summary and
future directions of this project and
where it might be
uh the main highlights of the project
were that both hydrophilic and
hydrophobic
are entrapped in the in a single neon
system
for applications in the treatment of
breast cancer and tuberculosis
and in both the studies the particle
size of the neozone was
less than 200 nanometer and the higher
and the entrapment efficiency for both
the projects were more than 70 percent
for all the trustees
also it showed a significant dynamic
effect in terms of their favorite
counterparts
and also they showed a good amount of
question release
for two to four days with a six month
stability under battery regulation
which is quite a good thing in a liquid
form
with coming to the end we'll discuss the
summary and future directions that
new zones can have can be potentially
used now that
is a self-assembly-based nano carrier
it as foreign therapeutic drug delivery
option for
many various applications
this can be used for cognitive therapy
as well
as well as different groups of drug
delivery is envisioned
by your preparing this specific kind of
neurons using
the ethanol injection method or any
other method which
the researchers might use in the future
also
in lieu of the traditional therapy
it is envisioned that this combinative
therapy using
new zones or any other lipid carriers
is a way for a better and smarter
treatment options
the future and some limitations of the
study is that
use of some smart molecules for
targeting specific areas in the body you
may provide a balanced option for the
treatment
also using better individual model
and using this museum
for performing better review studies
just to
confirm their validity in the euro
system
can be done and must be done for a
better therapeutic outcome
and better scalability in terms of
industrial application
also the intracellular state of this
museum
must be done in the future and the
underlying mechanism of it must be
studied as to
why they remain stable in this
system and how they specifically act on
the cell
a small amount of that we as we have
seen that was done
in the drug uptake studies where the
neutral uptake was
carried out or was studied using both
fluorescence microscopy and
close cytometric studies showing that
with
drug entrapment uh the density of the
vesicles gets increased and
ultimately increases their uptake in the
cellular
further applications in different areas
as well
there are also some applications coming
out in food technology
and even in situ engineering and the
development of buyers
this has some differences for my
presentation
both these studies have been
successfully published
in several journals one has been
published in journal of pharmaceutical
sciences which was
for the anti-cancer neurons and was
selected in the
virtual h2 title most original and most
significant scientific contribution
and tuberculosis uh what has been
published in
following surfaces a journal
there are also some other publications
in work and i also
just published recently two days back
of the same concept we have used for the
new zones
for application is alzheimer's disease
treatment
which we will share with the team after
i get the
official link of the publication
this is some other publications of mine
and this brings me to the end of my talk
i would specifically like to thank the
labruz team
for giving me this wonderful opportunity
and a platform to
present my research and share some ideas
for the
fellow researchers and audiences so
thank you very much for listening to me
and i will
allow some questions about this research
and i would love to
contribute in any way if you want to
talk with me
or you want to contact me you can
directly uh
connect with me on linkedin i can show
you that
so thank you very much